[Music]
there's something in this town that's
brand new called the golden collar
awards okay oh and i know you know what
i'm talking about
it's the oscars for animals and for dogs
right yeah and uh it's and and and so
different dogs uh and different animals
go up for best role or best you know
best actor yes and uh some good some not
so good okay you work with a dog named
joe yeah uh on this movie series you do
called jesse stone yeah and you uh joe
was nominated joe is the finest
canine actor i've ever worked with right
or any animal really chimp anything yeah
of all the animals you've worked with
and you've worked with some animals in
your dad better than zeus and apollo i
hate to say it okay this is the best one
and your dog lost to uggie from the
artist
is that right
yeah okay i mean now
i saw uggy i mean how could you not they
put them at the academy awards red
carpet and stuff and he's cute
you know and and and i think we have
pictures here too let's just take a clip
there is okay there's uggie who won and
look well there's the with the golden
globes yeah well that you heard the
audience go oh people immediately
respond to ugly people
as much as i like him and he's a cute
dog he kind of panders a little bit you
know he'll i bet i didn't see the artist
but i'll bet augie did the
thing and and that's just called being a
dog what are you talking about
but hi betty
i need a tongue i bet occasionally he
urinated
you can't hold that obvious yeah no but
that's see joe your dog is a golden
retriever who loves affection
playing
reggie
who has a problem with affection and
commitment
joe has layers joe has subtext
is interesting there he is
there he is
no i don't know if that's him showing
real emotion or if you just uh snapped a
photo after he took his kibble away you
know oh please it's in the eyes okay
well that that's clearly you've gone
insane um
but i say that with the greatest respect
oh thank you uh no you really believe in
uh in in joe as an actor joe um when you
do scenes with joe uh do you feel like
you are communicating as actors yeah
well he he kind of plays reggie who is
is like a guy he's he's jesse's roommate
and conscience and jesse drinks too much
so
that that's kind of a problem and joe
communicates thoughts not only to me
but to the audience okay this i gotta
see we have a clip here
uh of a scene uh from uh from jesse
stone benefit of the doubt and this is a
scene where we actually get to see the
two of you working together let's uh
judge this acting performance shall we
let it roll
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
thank you
i
i thought that was very powerful but
when they showed the shot of the drink
in the foreground and the dog in the
background i thought oh the dog's an
alcoholic
jesse is an alcoholic and the dog being
his conscience but see it was kind of
funny here but but that's unbelievably
intense in the in the show i mean
you show it out of context and it looks
kind of stupid but
but joe was working you can see it in
the eyes
[Applause]
i've never seen you i've known you for
years i've never seen you this
passionate about anything well i'm
passionate about joe you're yeah yeah
yeah this dog is really an auggie uh no
offense but but you know
he ought to be in the business for a
while before he pops off like he stood
you're angry at the dog from the artist
no no i love the dog and the artist
you said you didn't even see the artist
oh
[Laughter]